you
yes i'd like to itl
uh
this is an amendment to hp 1238
and it amends the bill
uh
by
adding more language at the end of
section three e
the same place that the previous change
was
it says opportunity for development of
such housing shall not be prohibited or
unreasonably discouraged by use of
municipal planning and zoning powers or
by unreasonable interpretation of such
powers including but not limited to
prohibitions on the building of
multi-family dwelling units in
residential or non-residential zones
provided that such units meet all other
applicable standards
and then at further down under local yet
land use planning and regulatory powers
innovative land use controls it proposes
to amend rsa 674 colon 21 comma 4a
to read as follows
after it talks about inclusionary zoning
inclusionary zoning includes but is not
limited to density bonuses growth
console exemptions the building of
multi-family dwelling units and
residential or non-residential zones and
a streamlined application process
um
so i move that we adopt the amendment
yes representative gallagher second
would you like to just uh speak to your
memory
no sir i merely introduced it because it
needed to be introduced is there any
seeing none uh
[Music]
yes
representative melvin
no
representative
yes
representative perez would you like to
join us at the
grab grab a
the adoption of the amendment passes
okay
so
yes representative power thank you mr
chair i'm having difficulty hearing the
proceedings here people are not using
the microphones okay
so please remember that if you're going
to be speaking to use your mic and if
you're done speaking turn your mic off
thank you
so representative melvin we have a
uh
amendment that just passed you have
yes i'd like to itl
i don't know if we can i tell amen at
the same time
i think only otp is gonna be invented
right
okay so we have uh
a motion to itl the bill as amended
yes representative gallagher um
so
i was just wondering uh so
remember discussion
previously um
and discussion previously there's some
concern over
some of the
wording
in the bill whether the language was
accurate or not um could someone remind
me or clarify for me whether
we managed to clear that up with the
amendment we just passed or not
yes representative
i would say no
that the that the amendment improves the
bill
but
i think there are still questions about
i'm not opposed to this bill i think
that
it's unlikely to have
a powerful effect on the production of
workforce housing simply because
it's an opt-in bill
under the innovative land use controls
and historically we've seen that those
very rarely get used
and when they
do have
very little effect on the actual
increase in workforce housing thank you
representative and is there further
discussion
yes president mesuri thank you mr chair
and i'll recall that even the sponsor
said that the bill when first introduced
was somewhat vague and possibly
toothless
um that was the quote that he used on
this and that the amendment
might improve it which i think i think
we can agree at least
to some degree improves it a little bit
but not to the point
uh as my friend just said uh to the
point where um it does a whole lot
or does he intended it gets the intended
result thank you
further discussion yes representative
thank you mr chair um
i
i want to echo what my colleagues have
said so far you know it's a step in the
right direction but very
vague
and not imp you know
it's not going to solve the crisis we
have with the workforce housing
so this is
you know even though the amendment was a
little bit
trying to improve it so
it will not
work in my community or it wouldn't help
so
with that i will oppose this as um or
i'll support itl thank you thank you uh
additional true yes representative trump
thank you mr chair
uh
as representative band said this is
a enabling
uh in that
the the towns have to have to adopted
innovative land use but uh
uh
i feel that uh
the vagueness of this
is uh
not in the best interest of towns
because it's uh it can be taken since it
can be taken almost anyway
uh it could probably be taken in a way
that's not intended so i uh i will
support the itl
further discussion
mr clerk please take a roll
okay itl 1238 uh vice chairman los alas
yes click folks yes representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative johnson
yes
representative melvin
yes representative
yes
representative power yes
represent majority
yes
representative mangapudi
representative
yes
representative perez
representative gallagher
yes representative ron yes
and chairman dolan yes
uh 16-0 okay without objection i'll move
mr chair yes i just have a
comment or um
to share
one of uh
my constituents
and a business multiple business owner
handed this to me
this weekend
communities and consequences the
unbalancing of new hampshire
human
ecology and what we can do about it it's
all about the housing and
in outward migration of youngsters and
inward migration so i would like to
make an offer that i would get some
copies and distribute it to our
committee members and especially mr
chair
you and you know the leadership so
i would be happy if uh
it will be
accepted thank you uh representative
that would be uh
very thoughtful of you
please at your leisure please make the
have those copies be made and we'll pass
them out i will order the books okay and
i'll hand it to you as a gift to my
thank you colleagues okay
mr chair yes
just uh uh just a quick question the
report for the last bill 1238 will be
coming from the majority or do you need
uh
representative melvin melvin okay in
charge of that thank you if you could
coordinate the minority
okay
and the next bill we're going to take up
is house bill 1259
which is relative to the election and
resignation of members of school boards
and elected budget committees
mr chair yes
i have i move itl and house bill 1259 is
a discussion can i speak to the motion
this is a uh
interesting bill it's uh i'm sure you've
probably heard that this said before
that it's a solution in search of a
problem
um
i find it be very complicated
the uh the change to the bill is uh
let's see one two three four five six
six lines of a single run-on sentence
it's uh hard to understand
uh
i can't
i can't support the bill i will support
the ital
thank you
yeah and let me say that
this has to do with the election
with an election of school boards and
budget committees i think we have to be
very careful
when we as legislators are looking to
put
rules in around uh elected members that
could cause them to to fall out of
office i think we have to be very
careful of that
not to say this this would happen in
this case but just as a general comment
so uh we have a motion on the floor
itl and it's been seconded
i don't see any further discussion so at
this point we'll take a roll
thank you mr chairman uh itl 1259. i'm
sorry
thank you
okay itl
uh vice chairman los alas
yes collect votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative johnson yes
representative melvin
yes
representative here
yes representative power yes
representative
yes
representative gilman
representative megaputi
yes
representative
representative perez
yes
representative gallagher
representative wrong
yes and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 16-0
as we move on to our next bill the house
bill
which is relative to the municipal
authority for roads and sidewalk
closures
representative lasallis do you have a
motion yes mr chairman uh i uh
uh
move that this
motion's been made in 2nd do we have any
mr chair yes
um
during the outbreak of covid
made some very creative uses
of streets and extended sidewalks
out into the street
particularly
the
city of nashua
adding to the seating capacity
that was restricted by covid
as i read this bill i think that
it would
hinder
municipalities
from doing that
so
i i think that
you know that the municipalities were
very creative
and that it worked out great and
so i wouldn't want to change that
thank you further discussion mr chair
yes representative manjufudi uh thank
you mr chair since my city was mentioned
i do totally agree
um nashua did very creatively
extend the pleasure of having sidewalks
open
streets narrowed and make it
dining outside and safely
under the pandemic so i think that gave
the local control of what's best for the
community and this businesses
appreciated that so this is i think
community coming together so i totally
agree that this
bill will take away and itl is the best
motion for it right thank you
we have uh
a motion to itl
in a second
seeing none will the clerk take the role
okay itl
1267. uh vice chairman los alas
yes collect votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative johnson
yes
episode of melvin yes
representative
representative power
yes
robert majori
representative gilman yes
representative megafooty
yes
representative
representative perez
yes
representative gallagher
[Music]
yes
and chairman dolan yes
16-0
without objection i'll place this on the
to exec is house bill 1268
which is limiting the authority for city
we have an amendment
on 1268 do we have a
anyone who would like to introduce that
amendment
okay
since
the amendment
is not being introduced
okay
so
uh representative lasalis do you do you
have a motion on 1268 without the
amendment
yes mr chair um
i move that uh
house bill 1268 b
otp'd
okay and is there a second
i'll second that okay
the motion's been made and seconded is a
discussion among the committee on 1268
yes representative majori
thank you mr chair i'm going to vote
against the otp on here the language
that was struck
in the bill that we are considering
which is which is the bill itself
strikes for the well-being and includes
for clear and present danger if the
argument is that
well-being is ambiguous
then i cannot see how clear and present
danger is
provides any more clarity whatsoever
we understand that uh
we understand that it is it is critical
for city councils to be able
to respond
to instances that happen in their
community
to be able to do that uh in a way that
is
responsible reactive and timely uh i
think what this bill does is strips them
of that responsibility or
strips them
of that
of that ability and puts
i think will ultimately put the
residents of that town in clear and
present danger so i'll be voting against
the otp
thank you
further discussion
yes representative wrong
i will also be voting against the otp i
i see this bill as just another attack
on local control locally if uh locally
elected officials are in the best
position to
assess
the well-being and what they need to do
to ensure the well-being of their
community and this just removes further
their ability to respond to their their
uh cities and towns
thank you for any further discussion he
has represented manchapudi thank you mr
chair from my public hearing notes
there was
except
the president presenting the bill
those who testified all opposed it
i really didn't have any one that
supported so
you know um
with that and also
taking away the local control is not
what we aspire
and i know this is my first term here on
this
committee but
the
new hampshire way of local control is
as
very sacred in that sense so
with that i'll vote against otp thank
you representative tripp
thank you mr chair
uh
i don't read the bill the same as
the others that have spoken against it
do
but the thing that i
think is
most noteworthy about the bill is that
it limits
anything
that the
the
governing body does to 10 days this is
something that i think that we learned
from the pandemic
ten days to flatten the curve you know
can usually turn into something else and
i think uh
ten days to uh
for the any ordinance to be in effect
is long enough thank you
thank you
yes representative i'm majori
um
we just we just went itl on a bill for
allowing uh cities and communities to be
able to use their sidewalks as they see
best and noted the fact that nashua did
an excellent job responding
during covid to be able to open up their
sidewalks i guess that would have only
been good for 10 days according to this
bill
any further discussion
yes representative wrong yeah i'd like
to give an example um i spend summers in
moultonborough and the lake where i
spend my time up there has been subject
to cyanobacteria blooms the last two
years
and
sometimes that clear and present danger
of entering the water during a toxic
bloom may last a lot longer than 10 days
des does not have the capability at
present to be able to
manage those blooms and provide
effective notification to the residents
we need to be able to rely on local
officials to determine whether
an advisory on that lake should continue
past 10 days so
that's just one example of how this law
puts citizens at risk because people
that at the state level who who are in a
position to help them
are not able to
and the
and we can't handcuff the local
officials from doing their job thank you
representative tripp
to begin with reverence and
the first comment
uh
placing
diners on the sidewalks is a clear and
present danger so i don't think that
that would be applicable to this
bill
i
i don't i don't know whether
putting you know chemicals in the water
would be applicable either
uh
the uh
i would i would think that if there's
something that
is
a health hazard that
this bill would not be applicable
but
i i still
support the ital
representative
thank you mr chair
if we have learned anything from the
pandemic
you know which has lasted this is the
third year which is luckily we are going
in the right direction
ten days of any ordinance is not enough
especially when it comes to health and
safety of the
public
so
you know and tying the local
um elected bodies with a local authority
to not be able to react
uh in a positive way to
protect the safety of the community
this would hinder that so with that you
know like my colleague representative
maggiore suggested this goes you know we
can't have
different opposing
bills
because the one that gave the local
authority to do the sidewalk and then
say no you can't do another ordinance
which relates to that so this kind of is
opposing some of the safety features
that the local authorities can have so
with that i will oppose otp
yes representative wrong
i just want to address representative
tripp's comments about blooms
they're not chemicals that are added to
the lake there are natural bacteria and
they're the oldest living organisms on
the face of the earth and they reside in
the sediment of a lake or river and
under certain conditions like warming
which we've been experiencing a trend
and increased runoff and sediment
disruption they go into a hyper growth
mode which is called a bloom
and these bacteria release neurotoxins
and anatoxins
which have led to the deaths of animals
the past couple years pets
it's made people very sick
des documents all of this
last year alone there were 30 lakes that
suffered cyan at least one cyanobacteria
bloom but des admits
that there are many many others they
only have one person in charge of that
program and she left because she was too
overwhelmed they haven't been able to
fill that position yet
it's extremely serious
researchers at unh and dartmouth and
around the world have linked the toxins
of these blooms to
many neurological diseases
some of you may be remember in
muscoma lake several years ago there was
a cluster of als which they are linking
to cyanobacteria blooms in that lake
many new hampshire residents don't know
that these happen because des is so
under resourced to be able to address it
there was a bill that just passed
unanimously in resources
to
require des to come up with a plan to
address these but that plan won't be
available until late next year
and in the meantime we need to rely on
local officials to be able to make a
determination
um if these blooms require
limitations or warnings or some action
on behalf of the local community to warn
people and restrict them from going into
these waters thank you
okay we have a motion
in a second
to limit the authority for city council
bylaws and ordinances
this is hb 1268 as a reminder
uh the amendment was not considered
mr clerk would you please take a roll
ought to pass on
one two six eight uh vice chairman los
alas yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative johnson
yes
representative melvin yes
representative here
representative power yes
representative gilman no
representative megapootie no
representative
no
representative perez
representative gallagher
no
representative
chairman dolan yes
thank you
mr chair yes there will be a minority
report on this and uh i will write that
okay and representative salus you're
going to write the majority
thank you
our next bill
this morning is going to be
house bill 1272
which limits the authority of town
representative power do you have a
motion yes i'd like to make a motion
on house bill 1272 ought to pass
i'll second time thank you
yes representative
thank you mr chair and this is
another one that is
taking away local control and especially
in the
tail end of a pandemic
to have local officers i mean local
health officers not have the ability to
react to the community
is
really
very disturbing
and um so
i cannot support otp
on this one thank you representative
further discussion yes representative
matt jory thank you mr chair um
hb 79 or i'm sorry health health
officers
are guided in their responsibility by
statute to strip them of this
responsibility right now and to limit
to limit
um the adoption of their action to 10
days again speaks to
speaks to
i don't know what logic here um
in in if this is in response to a
pandemic we have certainly seen that
that we have lasted years
and not days i think you need to give
the local health officers the
responsibility
uh to effectuate uh their their uh their
actions or take the act to to to act on
their judgment their best judgment
um and do that in a time frame that is
responsible within their communities so
i'll be voting against the otp thank you
representative further discussion on
phil us representative tripp
uh
i think that the ten day limit is uh is
a positive in this bill uh not a
negative uh
i seem to remember that uh
the governor when uh
he he was uh
renewing his executive orders every uh
30 days or something i don't remember
exactly but uh there's nothing in this
bill that uh limits the health officer
from renewing uh what they
proposed so
that's why i support the otp
thank you representative
thank you mr chair
just responding to you know we
pandemic is
i hope it's one time in my lifetime here
not we won't face this but
knowing what we went through 10 days
was too short even to see the response
or re you know
to see the effect of the ordinance or
the uh the health office's
recommendation
and
ability for the local health officers
to be able to react and respond
to the health and well-being of the
community
i'm just shaking my head i i just cannot
see the logic behind it
thank you representative wrong
thank you mr chair
um i know the motion on the floor is otp
and there's concern about the 10 days
but there was an amendment submitted i
was wondering why that wasn't being
h
it removes the 10 days yeah the
amendment's not being considered because
it was it wasn't brought up by anybody
okay thank you
procedure if if you know of an amendment
that you want to see introduced
please inform me right away and we'll
we'll take the amendment first
but it's
it really puts us in a bind if we we try
to take the amendment last
so
mr chair yes i have a question of the
procedure
um
i'm just
wondering what is your pleasure of the
chair
you you know when you ask for a motion
you know if we have
another motion that we want to see it
jumping before or would you recognize or
would you ask for a motion
you know if anybody has a motion because
at least for me it seems like
you are specifically asking
representatives to make a motion so it's
a
it feels to me it's like a predetermined
so i just want to clarify that
my perception is
not correct or incorrect or correct well
as you as you have uh observed that
if we take emotion if i take a motion
to to itl or to otp if somebody quickly
lets me know that there is a motion
awaiting to be heard what i'll do is i
back off that initial motion
allow the amendment to be heard we'll
vote on the amendment then we'll go back
to the original motion to see how we
want to dis disposition the bill based
on that
as far as
beyond that
i am uh
operating by the by the rules of the uh
of the committee and and of the house so
um
yes representative wrong um since it's
the original bill that's on the floor
i'd just like to
say that i'll be voting against the otp
my notes from the public hearing show
considerable amount of
concerns the committee had
the
subjective term of repugnant
um the term any other authority which is
very vague with no definition
um there were several other things that
were wrong in fact the the prime sponsor
was so concerned that she's the one that
brought the
amendment forward so i'll be voting no
on otp
thank you
yes representative
and i would thank you mr chair and i
would add to that one of one of my
concerns is when we look at language
that says for the purpose of addressing
locations
that present a clear and present danger
imagine isolating a certain area
of a community that represents a clear
and present danger but not the entire
community
um i think that some of the amendments
that we had in some of the discussions
might have cleared that up but i have to
vote against this bill for
multiple reasons including that one
all right we have a motion on the floor
on house bill 1272 otp no amendment has
been considered
uh mr clerk would you take a role please
okay otp on 1272. uh vice chairman los
alas yes
clerk vote yes representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie representative
johnson
yes
representative melvin yes
representative yes representative power
yes
representative majority no
representative gilman no
representative
no
representative perez
representative gallagher
no
representative
chairman dolan yes
thank you
representative power you're going to
and
i'll get your name before the end of the
all right next is house bill 1289 which
is relative to application for
abatements
and the authority to abate prior to
year's
taxes for certain homeowners
is there a motion to be made mr chair
yes i'd like to make a motion to itl
okay is there a second
okay motion's been made and seconded is
there discussion on the motion
yes mr chair this bill
would
make it
so that
homeowners could ask for an abatement
simply because they live
near a class five or six road
where
there are
ohrvs
that use that road
i think that
the situation where although i can
sympathize
with people that
are inconvenienced
by
the use of ohrvs
on these class five and six roads
i think to allow abatements
would be a step in the wrong direction
so
i
yes
i uh
thank you
i remember during the testimony that
there was a lot of discussion about uh
uh
how how this came into being and uh
the uh
it was it was done somewhat uh
clandescently
and uh it's only after the uh the
approval was made that uh
the people found out that they would be
having uh ohrvs you know going down
their road
uh
i think the issue
with uh having
atvs or ohrbs on the road is a valid one
but
requesting abatements is in my mind not
the path to take the path to take would
be to
reverse the approval
of the atvs on a road because they're
still going to be dusty it's still going
a bad thing
that's noisy
and
rather than asking for a couple dollars
the the correct solution is uh
reversing the approval of the use of the
the road is a is a ohrv trail
and that's why i'll be uh supporting
help me catch up my notes here i have
a motion
to itl from representative loseless was
there a second from representative ayer
it was
okay i just didn't have it noted thank
you
is there further discussion yes
representative guthrie
uh thank you mr chairman i'd like to uh
it just seemed to be an awful situation
in in the testimony that was given
but i don't think that the uh given an
abatement for a
noise problem
uh would uh help
the people who
are
having the problem
i think there are other avenues to solve
this problem
either with uh
some kind of a noise uh ordinance
uh i really uh i'm glad it's not in my
town because it is an awful situ
situation but i have to vote for itl
mainly because an abatement would not
solve this problem it would just be
begging your question
further discussion representative rung
yes i'm going to be voting against the
itl
as we heard in the testimony from
some residents up there it's it's not
about the money it's about justice and
it's about the town acknowledging that
their property
has been negatively impacted by these
ohrvs i want to bring your attention to
an article that was in friday's edition
of the new hampshire union leader
the headline is judge says state
inadequately compensated gorham
landowners over atv use i just want to
read a paragraph from that a judge has
ruled that the town and state
inadequately compensated the owners of
several residential properties along u.s
route 2 when they permitted atvs to
operate on and near the road
in an order he signed february 15 in
grafton county superior court judge
lawrence mcloyd said the decision by the
new hampshire department of
transportation the department of natural
and cultural resources and the town of
gorham to permit use of atvs quote
constitutes an unconstitutional taking
of the plaintiff's properties by inverse
condemnation pursuant to which each
plaintiff homeowner is entitled to just
compensation as damages end quote
so um what i see this is yes i mean
i think the state and the town need to
reverse their decision to allow atvs on
this on these trails but in the meantime
and regardless of that
this should
constitute good cause it's not giving
these landowners an abatement but it's
just allowing this to be a reason they
can seek an abatement and i think it's
the right thing to do so i will vote no
representative
thank you mr chair if i'm looking at my
notes from the public hearing there was
a suggestion or one of the
testifying they said make this to all
public ways
prohibiting atvs on all public ways that
way it reduces
the
traffic and it limits to its um only the
trails
and also
nhma
referred to multiple
bills that
you know would impact so
this is a issue
and it's a one specific community is
facing and this
is an instance where
local control cannot do much
it has the state has to respond or we
have to respond to the local
ordinance i mean not ordinance the tax
because it's a state thing
and it's this is the reverse of what we
usually
advocate in this community in this
committee so
i think itl is just
link and so
down the road and um
i have a hard time uh just ignoring the
plea of the
residents
of a community in our state and i would
oppose itl thank you
uh i have a comment as
well i'm going to be last so is there
any other comments to uh
i've seen none
i remember the hearing on this and i i
remember my thoughts on this
there was a lot of passionate discussion
about
folks that had a lot of noise a lot of
dust and
interference
with the good use of their property by
the ohrvin
issues
and that the
the uh
the folks that were in favor of this
were
were thinking that the
then an abatement would be a
proper compensation for that
that issue
my thought is that while i'm very
sympathetic to their problems
uh and understand how abatements are
used it's my thought that
that
the folks who have those complaints will
not be satisfied with an abatement
they'll put a couple hundred dollars in
their back pocket
however the the noise and the dust and
the dirt
and the nuisance doesn't go away
and that's the real issue
so my
response during the hearing
to some degree was
i think they need to get at the root
cause of the problem
and solve that
and the need for an abatement will go
away or the abatement can be judged on
the merits
of of the
of the tax law that applies in that
community
i think that someone who applies for an
abatement and gets the abatement
that it's my assumption they will not be
satisfied with that and they'll be right
back in front of their local government
again the following year
and
with the abatement in their hand but
they're still going to be upset with how
with how the situation was mitigated or
not mitigated so with with that thought
while very sympathetic to those people
who
had a who have a problem because this is
still going to be a problem for a while
i don't think abatement is the right
mr chairman representative gilman thank
you
um i'd also like to point out that there
are two bills i believe one was in
judiciary and one was in resources
that deal with the same thing of class
five and six roads and the use of
recreational vehicles i do not know the
disposition of those bills it's not
recorded on the house website um but
i would like to say uh either those
bills should have come to us that's one
thing um
but that we should wait to see
how what those results were
yes representative manjapuri
thank you mr chair i mean
is it uh appropriate to say let's do a
um interim study instead of itl at least
the topic of discussion will stay on and
i agree
with some of the
sentiments of you know abatement will
not solve the issue uh for the residents
there is a motion on the floor itl only
if that is reversed the next one would
be right
so that's a motion that you're you're
projecting you want to make
i'm just asking would wouldn't that be
the
way to go when we when we dispose of the
current motion that would emotion that
motion if the bill is still alive that
yes representative wrong yeah one point
i'd like to make also um to follow up on
representative man djibouti's comment is
the sponsors of this bill um
it's a bipartisan bill uh representative
renzullo who is chair of the resources
recreation and development committee
brings it forward with representative
gould who's also a long time
member of that committee and
representative gottling she's a
democrat from
from sunapee so i know this has been a
huge issue for that committee and
following up on representative
manchapudi's
suggestion if the otp is does fail i
would support itl and see if we can
bring in people from this other
committee to work on it as well because
they have dealt with several bills on
this issue thank you it's itl on them
any further discussion before we uh put
it to a vote
yes
yes i i agree a little bit with um
someone just said that um yes this is
can be like a temporary fix but
the problem may come back you know
someone can get money from the
um the issue but uh they they're gonna
come back for more and then that's gonna
be a local local issue not not for us to
one more thing um in the um
resources and recreation and development
excuse me the the bill they had was to
go to interrupt interim study for ohrv
use in the state
and it was found ought to pass
21 to zero
and
i believe that this would be a good
choice because
while the state encourages the use of
ohrvs as a pleasure vehicle and a
tourism
aspect
we can see from this bill and the
other one in
judiciary that ohrvs are becoming a
problem so maybe we are
defeating ourselves in our purpose of
the uh
of being a
tourism state i'm sorry i couldn't
remember
but i believe it
the commission the committee report 21-0
of an interim or study
commission is in order thank you
yes representative
matt giore thank you mr chair two things
one you're going to have to have the
last word so prepare to say something
and
secondly
i didn't want to pile on but noting what
representative gilman has just said and
seeing that this did come out 21-0
if we could get to an interim study to
see how we might be able to help those
folks i would be a hundred percent on
board with that
thank you
now you got to say something
okay um
a very debatable issue uh because
those
people
some people feel strongly one way or the
other
and
some people also believe that the
solution at hand
it might be buried and not
not so obvious so i'm gonna i'm gonna
recommend to
those on the committee
that
although there's a there is a motion to
itl this
that
i'm going to recommend that we vote down
the itl
yeah that would that would work
mr chairman
i will withdraw my motion to itl the
bill
representative
what representative would you withdraw
representative lasallus was withdrew his
motion
okay so we
we don't have a motion on the floor
representative vann
um i move that we send this bill
to interim study
motion's been made and seconded
for interim study yes representative
guthrie
i understand what's going on that
there's a lot of sympathy with the
situation i think it's the sympathy is
well taken however the board is
the bill is to abate for this serious
problem and i think you can talk this
to death
but
i don't think the solution to the
problem
is has anything to do with an abatement
i think the board of selectmen could in
fact
recognize
the situation and abate for it if they
want
so i don't even think it's necessary so
i think it's begging the question to
move in this direction and i cannot
uh vote for the
current motion
and i would hope that i would have hoped
that we stayed with the itl thank you mr
yeah i i support the interim study
um and this i just want to remind the
committee this is not granting
abatements it's just acknowledging that
this situation exists
and that
because it exists and especially after
this
this court ruling that it does allow
those people to go before their town and
ask for an abatement for good cause it
doesn't mean the abatement is going to
be granted but it just is recognizing
that this situation exists and i think
um studying this more with especially
with our colleagues from the resources
um will inform us to move forward to
help with develop a comprehensive
solution to what they're experiencing
thank you
okay interim study for uh house bill
west chairman silas
yes
click votes yes representative tripp yes
representative guthrie
representative johnson
yes
representative here no
representative
yes
yes representative perez
representative gallagher
yes
representative wrong yes
and chairman dolan yes
okay um
ask
rich
you want to write the majority report
and i was in majoria wait for your input
on that minority um
mr chair i don't i don't know that there
were any democrats who voted in for no
on the interim study were there
no
okay
right i think representative los alas is
going to do the the
report i will gladly uh pass that to you
do i do i need to accept that gratitude
your graciousness
i do so
okay so you're gonna write the maturity
we got it uh it's gonna be
and uh of the three
no votes who volunteer to write the
okay next is house bill 1293 which is
relative to the design of sewerage or
waste disposal systems for a person's
representative
mr chair may i make a motion
yes you may
otp on house bill 1293
okay is there a second i'd like to
second that
can i speak to my motion yes please too
uh
apparently this bill has been around i
mean that this situation has been around
for a while and uh the from the
testimony i heard
it's not a good idea to let uh
a home improvement guy design his own
septic system
uh there's uh
it's it's more of a science than an art
and uh if it's done improperly even
after the
the des
reviews the uh
uh the plan it could be
uh it could have effects that are
noticed
essentially all it does is remove the uh
the ability for a homeowner to design
his own septic system and this is why i
support the bill
is there any further discussion on the
bill yes representative majorie thank
you mr chair um as many of us sit on
select boards in our town i have for a
long long long time
this was
kind of a
oh speak sophomorically this is a duh
moment i'm like this exists you can do
that i had no idea so i'm all in favor
of the off the path because i don't
think you should be doing this but i
feel bad that i didn't even know you
could
thank you
if i write the report that language
would not be in there representative was
was your motion to ipl or otp
yes representative mitch putin thank you
mr chair
um
in my notes
from the testimony
it says oh so you can do your own
neurosurgery if you want on yourself
so if
it's alludes to that way of
more you know
so it's
i think octopass is the right motion
for this
yes as i remember the testimony
the thing that really struck me was when
des
came in and and
testified
the inordinate amount of time that they
have to spend
on these self-designed septic systems
and they have
you know
follow-up questions and follow-up
questions and they just spend an awful
lot of time
and
where
in the case of a professional
who designs the septic systems
they don't have that sort of issue
so i will be voting in support of the
otp
yes representative power thank you mr
chair um i would like to note that
the the ability to design a septic
system is different than
the ability of a homeowner to say do
electrical work inside their house or
renovate a bathroom or
you know finish off a basement
septic to system design
is is not trivial
there's a lot of knowledge that needs to
go into that
soil mechanics is part of that
and also the technology for
the um for the septic
systems themselves it's rapidly changing
as does other um you know technologies
so it's it's i would say it's rare for a
person to just to have that that
knowledge
and so the difference with a homeowner
doing a diy project in their house
versus a septic system it can impact
the aquifers and wells
in the in the neighborhood and also the
environment and i would also lastly like
to point out
that
this
takes away the
ability
of the homeowner to submit a plan
and like the representative los alas
said
the plan
needs to be approved
and if somebody doesn't really have the
background or the experience to
submit a plan it's it's requiring a lot
of
the department of environmental services
their their resources
so i i support
the motion ought to pass thank you
representative
seeing no further comment
my last comment on this is
when i think of this bill
i think of a couple first couple things
the knee-jerk reaction is well gee
i'm the homeowner
why can't i design my own
system
leave me alone
however i may not always be the
homeowner
i may sell this house
to a nice young couple that's deciding
to move into my old neighborhood
and when they move in
they may find that the septic system
that i designed
it doesn't work or doesn't fit
the needs that they have
so
i would think that we would want the
same reason we want the building code to
be followed
subsequent owners need to have some
assurance that what was done was done
legally and correct so
with that input i'll be supporting the
utp
see no further questions uh mr clerk
would you take a role
okay it's uh otp on 1293
vice chairman los alas
click votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes representative guthrie
representative johnson
yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majori yes
representative gilman yes
representative mega poody yes
representative
yes
representative perez yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative wrong yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 16-0
without objection i'll put this on the
next bill
we're going to be
going through is house bill
and this is the bill that modifies
the duties of the housing appeals board
representative tripp do you have a
motion to make
yes i do
i move otp on house bill
1307 okay is there a second
yes
representative
melvin
makes a second as a discussion about
this particular bill may i speak to my
motion yes please ah
i'd like to start out by saying uh i'm
not against the uh
oops i'm on the wrong page
the housing appeals board but uh
i do think that uh
it's uh
it's
investigatory uh uh rain is
a little unlimited the fact is the uh it
actually says that but it's not limited
uh i think the bill does a good job of
clarifying what the housing appeal board
can
review
and uh
it changes it to uh
boards and uh commissions within the
the uh
the town
rather than just uh
any other uh
reasons they want to investigate so i i
support the otp thank you yes
representative
yes i'm going to oppose the otp because
in fact limiting it to the list that is
provided in the in the bill
does mean that for example the select
board is eliminated
and other boards which actually do make
decisions having to do with land use are
eliminated from the housing appeal
board's authority and i think that's a
mistake because sometimes that's
necessary for example parking
requirements sometimes belong to the
select board and that's an issue that
comes up often particularly in the case
of providing workforce housing
how much parking you require affects the
cost of that housing and preventing um
the housing appeals board from looking
at that
seems short-sighted
thank you representative majori
thank you mr chair i i don't i hope i've
never been shy about expressing my
opinions about the h.a.b and and how the
h.a.b came to be
um
but i'm not going to rehash all of those
i'm going to vote in favor of the ought
to pass here because i do think that
this seemingly simple change will
focus the hab on its responsibilities
and that focus to be on
the issue of housing um so i myself will
be voting in favor of the ought to pass
thank you are there any
further comments representative
thank you mr chair
if i remember
the
hearing
this is hab has been in place just very
brief uh time 2 3 last term or term
before it was passed so
two terms ago and they implemented one
term ago and so
uh thank you for correcting and um
having
seen that this hasn't been in place too
long enough to
[Music]
say it's working or not working but this
would narrow or at least clarifies the
role of the hab so i would be
supporting um
in favor of otp so this clarifies and
gives an opportunity to see how this
works
thank you there being no oh yes
representative ron
yes i'm going to vote against the otp
for a couple reasons one for the one of
the reasons representative
manjapudi state is it really hasn't been
in effect very long so i think we need
to have some more experience with them
we also had testimony from several
people that it would increase court
costs and length of time for someone to
get an issue adjudicated
so
i'm concerned about that i know the
courts are very backlogged even as it is
and adding on to this
when we have a housing board i think is
unnecessary we also heard testimony from
many people about
that wanted it i tealed
and these are people that are prime
stakeholders in our housing situation or
housing crisis
we heard from new hampshire housing stay
work play
housing action
senator
guin was against it so
i don't know i'm not ready just to
support an otp at this time i'm also
share the concerns that
some
authority local authorities like a
conservation commission boards
of selectmen and town councils which
also make decisions
are are exempted from this thank you
thank you
any further discussion seeing none
i'd like to ask the clerk to call a role
okay otp on 1307 uh vice chairman los
alas yes click votes yes representative
tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative johnson yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power
yes
representative majority yes
representative gilman
yes
representative megaputi yes
representative vann
no
representative perez
yes
representative gallagher
no
representative no
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 13-3
question
i'm happy to write the minority report
and represent a trip we write the
majority report
the next bill is house bill 1350.
this is relative to the procedure for
evaluation of property tax for property
representative mcdonald did you have a
motion you were considering
yes the motion is ito
and
representative lasalla said you have a
second i will second that
motion has been made and seconded is
there a discussion
yes representative majori
as a as i stated before and sorry to
continue on as a member of my select
board that has to do the revaluations
thank you for that representative
mcdonald and representative salas
and representative van can i get you to
click off your mic please
okay if that's there's no further
mr clerk would you call the vote on an
itl for
for 13.50
okay uh vice chairman losalas
yes click votes yes
representative tripp i vote yes
representative guthrie yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majori
yes representative gilman
yes
representative gallagher
representative run yes
yes
the 16 to zero the motion ito passes
without objection let's go on the
1365 is our next bill to consider which
allows towns and cities to tax
residential and non-residential property
at different tax rates
mr chairman yes
i'd like to
move
i'll second it
motion's been made and seconded it's a
discussion on the committee on this bill
mr chairman yes
the
the bill would allow
municipalities
to tax
residential and
commercial
property
at different rates
i think that this really
complicates the whole
tax
tax taxation
system
and it uh
could have the result of
uh having one class
of property
against another class of property
and
that's why i
am moving ito representative
i support the itl motion as well this is
one of the most anti-business bills i've
seen coming in a long time
we rely on a balanced tax base to
support our communities
and um and it's driven by the value of
property yes we do provide exemptions
and credits under cert
certain circumstances but
i don't think it's right for us to take
any
inhibit businesses from coming to new
hampshire coming to communities
to help support those communities
in fact i think it's a slap and a face
to businesses so i'll be voting um for
the ito any further comments yes
thank you mr chair um i'd like to also
remind people that
the apartments association of new
hampshire called this a slippery slope
single families and it will just
continue to have a different class of
structures or or
businesses or
residential uh just continue to be
uh going down this road of the tech
separate tax rates
thank you
representative manjuputi
uh thank you mr chair i would support
the itl
uh looking at my notes again on public
hearing
bia
came out and said
opposing because this is not only uh
against business uh
coming into your communities but it's
also pitting uh
residents against residential versus uh
business so it's it it's more a divisor
for
the community so with that i tell i
support the agency representative
gallagher did you have a comment
so
um
i think the idea behind the bill makes
intuitive sense to me um
i
um
i'd like to applaud represent the
sponsor of the bill
for being willing to
um look at states that
have different
ideological perspectives from his own
for inspiration for legislation and
i think the fact
that the bill is being portrayed as
anti-business is a good thing
i i think some of these businesses need
to be slapped in the face and
taxed more
but
i do think that some of the
implementation
needs
needs work though
i think there were some legitimate
questions
raised about say the tax software
needing to be updated the extra
complications as we create for dra and
etc so
um
i would urge the sponsor to
go study the states where this has been
implemented
more in depth and
then
um come back to us with
a bill
that
uh addresses
some move on to vote
seeing no further discussion i like to
ask the clerk to take a vote on house
bill 1365
it's been itl
uh motion's been to itl
by representative loseless
thank you mr chairman ito 1365
vice chairman los alas
yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes representative guthrie
representative johnson yes
representative
melvin yes
representative here
representative power yes
representative majority yes
representative yes
representative vann yes
representative perez
yes
representative gallagher
representative ryan yes
and chairman dolan yes
uh motion passes 16 to zero without
objection i'll put this on the consent
calendar
and we're
the next and last bill for today is
uh relative to the membership of local
land use boards
and i i want to ask representative tripp
if he had a motion
i do mr chair i vote i i move
jody do you have a second
yeah
thank you
i speak to my motion yes you can speak
to it
ah
this is this is a bill that uh never
dies it comes back every year
uh
i find it kind of amazing
that
when
when we had the testimony that they go
well portsmouth has this problem
and it doesn't seem that anybody else
has this problem
uh i spoke with
people from uh
our departments the building inspector
uh
planning board
department head and uh
i says well
you guys don't have a vote right and he
says well no we don't make decisions we
just provide uh
testimony and advice
you know and
i believe that's probably the situation
in most the towns in new hampshire
it
the only place that this
is a problem seems to be
portsmouth
so i think
this is a local problem
it should be solved locally and this is
why i support leaving
the
membership on
local boards
especially specifically
planning board this the way it is thank
you
is there further discussion from the
committee on this
bill yes for visitor majority
thank you mr cheryl i confessed to being
a bit myopic when this when i first saw
this bill uh thinking about my friends
in portsmouth being just down the road
in northampton and knowing what that
issue was and thinking this makes
perfect sense but then
forgetting uh and i'm i'm i feel bad
about the fact that i did forget that
there are so many communities throughout
new hampshire that rely on the expertise
of folks who sit on their boards and
that is critical especially
um that they may not have the the the
the number of people to serve
um and that this bill would limit their
ability to be able to tap into that
expertise from folks who may not
necessarily live in their community so i
support
the itl and agree with my friend
representative tripp
it's a further discussion
in the committee on this bill before we
take it to a vote
okay mr uh clerk uh hb 1374. it's been
itl
okay 1374 itl uh representative los alas
yes
votes yes representative tripp
representative guthrie
representative johnson
yes
representative melvin yes representative
here yes
representative power yes
representative missouri
yes
representative gilman
representative mangapudi yes
representative vann
yes
representative perez yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan yes
16-0
thank you
without objection i'll put this on the
consent calendar
before we leave i just wanted to
thank all of you for your professional
representation of your points of view
today
some
difficult and complex issues and we we
with
with being very cordial to each other
and i think that's a
that bodes well for this committee and
also thank you to the two subs that came
in
to help us out
and
i want to thank the ranking member also
for his help
uh and uh
representative los alas for filling in
for representative piamonte we did so
well maybe it has something to do with
tony being gone
be it spread upon the minutes that that
came from the chair
the uh i will i will say that as a
reminder we have one more session
tomorrow
same time same channel
and for the republicans please try to
get here at
and i think that's going to be it for a
while but i'll check with our
with our social director outside that
see how many more parties we're going to
have
i think they're going to be
some senate bills starting to drift
through
they're at a low level right now but
they won't be
shortly so
we'll start taking them up as they start
to accumulate but hopefully you get a
few days off
uh well deserved and again thank you
very much and
that's it for today
mr chair
as
representative perez
it was it was my honor and my pleasure
to like this is very very peaceful
session and it's my birthday so it was
like really cool to me
it was really cool to be here and it was
it was nice it was very peaceful and
very
like welcome environment so thank you
thank you
thanks
you